pour jean bernard gervais rédacteur en
chef du magazine médical en ligne
what's up doc les clusters ces fouilles
de l'épidémie vont forcément se
multiplient les bons élèves pourraient
être des pays comme par exemple en corée
du sud où l'est les tests se sont
multipliées avec vitesse grand v et
mauvais élèves pourraient être italie
donc là encore on a eu on a en fait à un
constat qu'il faut en fait nuancer avec
la situation française qu'il faut le
rappeler n'est pas encore arrivé au
stade de l'épidémie dont costa 3 nous
sommes encore au stade 2 de nouvelles
mesures sont prises chaque jour des
traitements commencent à apparaître
alors plutôt des traitements
prophylactiques car c'est plutôt les
traitements qui avait été utilisé dans
des précédentes épidémies de coronavirus
donc le constat en tous les cas dans sur
le territoire français n'est pas n'est
pas n'est pas pessimiste même si
finalement il faut s'attendre à une
recrudescence dans les jours qui
viennent à la fois en fait des décès et
aussi des ddd kloster qui vont se
multiplier pour atteindre et se
globaliser à l'ensemble en fait de
l'hexagone